Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams, and whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想先简单和大家分享一件正在进行中的激动人心的事。如果你曾想过如何创造能为你带来源源不断收入的模式，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺持续性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮你建立可持续的收入流，无论你是有志成为心理学家的人，还是心理健康专业人士，
or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself, and if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you wanna know more?
或者身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。此外，丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的专属链接参加挑战，还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士一对一咨询一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？
Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. What do Netflix, Dr. Julie Smith, and Headspace all have in common? It's that they've all found ways of working with more people without just offering
你当然想。快去我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。网飞（Netflix）、朱莉·史密斯（Dr. Julie Smith）博士和Headspace冥想应用有什么共同点？那就是他们都找到了在不单纯依靠一对一服务的情况下，服务更多受众的方法。
one-to-one. They are able to offer valuable content which helps their audience whilst also creating sustainable income for themselves. Now what if I told you that you as a psychologist or mental health professional could do the same? You could earn money while you sleep, when you go for a run, or even when you're spending time with your family. You could even earn money when you are in one-to-one sessions.
他们能够提供有价值的内容，在帮助受众的同时，也为自己创造了可持续的收入。现在，如果我告诉你，身为心理学家或心理健康专业人士的你，也可以做到这一点呢？你可以在睡觉时、跑步时，甚至在陪伴家人时赚钱。你甚至可以在进行一对一咨询的时候也在赚钱。
No, this isn't a rainbow unicorn. This isn't something that's too good to be true. It's all about working smarter, not just harder. As psychologists and mental health professionals, we are often so focused on helping others that we neglect to set up sustainable income streams for ourselves. But what if passive income could give you the financial freedom to work fewer hours, reduce burnout and focus on what truly lights you up? Today we are diving into why passive income is not just for massive names and corporate
不，这不是什么彩虹独角兽的虚幻传说，也不是好得令人难以置信的骗局。这完全是关于如何更聪明地工作，而不仅仅是更努力。作为心理学家和心理健康专业人士，我们常常把太多精力放在帮助他人上，以至于忽略了为自己建立可持续的收入来源。但是，如果被动收入能赋予你财务自由，让你减少工作时间、缓解职业倦怠，并专注于真正让你感到兴奋的事情呢？今天我们将深入探讨为什么被动收入不仅属于大品牌和大型企业，
companies. It's a game changer for psychologists too. Stay tuned because by the end of this episode, you'll have a roadmap for how to get started and I'll also be inviting you to a free Passive Income Challenge where you'll be able to take the first steps to your financial freedom. Hi, welcome along.
对心理学家来说，它同样能改变游戏规则。请继续收听，因为在本期节目结束时，你将拥有一份如何开始的路线图，同时我也将邀请你参加一个免费的被动收入挑战，让你迈出通往财务自由的第一步。嗨，欢迎收听。
I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. If you've been following me for a while, Hi, welcome along. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. If you've been following me for a while, you will likely know that I'm passionate about supporting the needs of aspiring psychologists, but also qualified psychologists throughout their careers. But I'm also all about achieving work-life balance and financial sustainability. For me, that looks at writing books such as the Clinical Psychologist Collective, but also running the Aspiring Psychologist membership
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我是一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你关注我有一段时间了，嗨，欢迎收听。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我是一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你关注我有一段时间了，你大概会知道，我热衷于支持有志成为心理学家的人的需求，同时也支持职业生涯各个阶段的合格心理学家。但我也同样追求工作与生活的平衡以及财务的可持续性。对我而言，这体现在撰写诸如《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）之类的书籍，同时还运营“有志心理学家会员社区”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），
and creating paid for courses and master classes on passive income for psychologists and mental health professionals. I want to show you how you can start to do the same. I know it might sound daunting, but I promise you it's not rocket science. I passionately believe that passive income is a must for qualified psychologists and mental health professionals and even if you are not yet qualified I still want you to take
并针对心理学家和心理健康专业人士开设关于被动收入的付费课程和大师班。我想向你展示如何开始做同样的事情。我知道这听起来可能有点令人生畏，但我向我保证，这绝不是什么高深莫测的火箭科学。我坚信，被动收入对于合格的心理学家和心理健康专业人士来说是必不可少的；而且即使你尚未获得资格认证，我也依然希望你关注这一点，
notice because you could even start to create passive income streams from your existing expertise right now and that's because it's not just about professional skills you could create passive or recurring revenue from your personal passions too. For example, I know of one woman who made a stack of cash teaching people to hula hoop, and another who made loads sharing her love of the theater. So if you have knowledge or a passion
因为你甚至可以从现有的专业知识中开始建立被动收入流。这是因为这不仅关乎专业技能，你还可以从个人的热情所在中创造被动收入或持续性收入。例如，我认识的一位女士通过教别人转呼啦圈赚了一大笔钱，还有一位女士通过分享她对戏剧的热爱赚了好多钱。所以，如果你有什么别人可能觉得有价值的知识或热情，你就已经拥有了一个被动收入的机会。
that others might find valuable, you already have a passive income opportunity. Perhaps you're feeling a bit hesitant, a bit wary about the idea of making money in your sleep or perhaps you think no psychology is a vocation, I didn't get into this for the money. I'd say that's probably quite a good job in the most part but it doesn't mean that you can't be wealthier, that you can't be more comfortable, that you can't have more time to focus on perhaps doing the really nice aspects of therapy like reflecting, like writing in your journals, like doing the formulation, perhaps depending on the medium that you work in by doing your
也许你对“在睡梦中赚钱”这个想法感到有些犹豫、有些警惕，或者你可能会认为：“不，心理学是一项天职，我干这个又不是为了钱。”我会说，在大多数情况下这或许是个不错的职业，但这并不意味着你不能变得更富有，不能过得更舒适，不能有更多时间专注于治疗中那些真正美好的环节——比如反思、写日志、做案例构思（formulation），也许根据你工作的媒介，还可以撰写过程记录（process notes），
process notes, but earning more money which supplements all of that for you so that you're not having to take on so many one-to-one clients. I think sometimes we can have kind of deep-seated beliefs about money and how it should or shouldn't come to us. Some of us even have kind of money trauma as well from our experiences in growing up or in our relationships past or present. This can really affect the way we think about money but also about how we prioritise and manage our finances and our financial well-being. But the truth is building a sustainable career in psychology for me at least means thinking beyond direct one-to-one work. It doesn't mean that you need to stop
同时赚取更多能补充这一切的收入，这样你就不用接那么多的一对一客户了。我想有时我们对金钱以及金钱应该或不应该如何到来，会抱有一些根深蒂固的信念。我们有些人甚至由于成长经历或过去、现在的恋爱关系，而带有某种“金钱创伤”。这确实会影响我们对金钱的看法，也会影响我们如何优先处理和管理我们的财务以及财务健康。但事实是，在心理学领域建立一个可持续的职业生涯——至少对我和而言——意味着要超越直接的一对一工作去思考。这并不是说你需要停止一对一的工作。
the one-to-one work. I love offering my trauma and grief therapy to clients. I never plan to stop. But by having passive income streams and recurring revenue streams, I have more time to do what I love without burnout. So today we are unpacking why passive income is essential for psychologists and mental health professionals, the biggest mindset blocks that stop you from getting started and the first simple steps to create income streams that really work for you and for your clients. Let's get started by talking about burnout. So many of us, regardless of the stage of our career, are juggling direct client work, paperwork, supervision, CPD and also trying to have a personal life too.
我非常喜欢为客户提供创伤和悲伤治疗，我从未打算停止。但通过拥有被动收入流和持续收入流，我有更多时间去做我热爱的事情，而不会感到职业倦怠。因此，今天我们正在剖析为什么被动收入对心理学家和心理健康专业人士至关重要、阻碍你开始的最大思维障碍，以及创造真正适合你和客户的收入流的头几个简单步骤。让我们从讨论职业倦怠开始。我们当中的许多人，无论处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，都在同时兼顾直接的客户工作、文书工作、督导、持续专业发展（CPD），还试图拥有个人生活。
The emotional toll of therapy can of course be high, so I think without alternative income streams many psychologists and mental health professionals might well find themselves on a direct route to feeling exhausted, overworked and underpaid. Passive income really helps by reducing reliance on one-to-one sessions, by providing financial security to help transition tricky phases like parenting, maternity, paternity leave, adoptive leave, illness, career transitions or even helping to care for your parents. It also gives you the time and the flexibility to explore your other passions or just, you know, sit around more or go to a spa or get up a bit later one day a week, two days a week.
治疗工作所带来的情感消耗自然是巨大的，所以我想，如果没有替代收入来源，许多心理学家和心理健康专业人士很可能会发现自己正走上一条筋疲力尽、过度劳累且报酬过低的直通车。被动收入确实大有助益，它能降低对一对一咨询的依赖，提供财务安全感，从而帮助你平稳度过那些棘手的阶段，比如育儿、产假、陪产假、领养假、生病、职业转型，甚至照顾父母。它还为你提供时间和灵活性去探索你的其他热情，或者只是，你知道的，多坐一会儿，去洗个温泉，或者一周有一天、两天起得晚一点。
You know, it gives you the chance to really begin to think about how you thrive. For me, passive income has allowed me to do more things like media work, brand partnerships, to run this podcast which absolutely takes a lot of time, to develop my membership community and to spend more quality time with my family and friends. What are the blocks then that stop us all from immediately rushing out and doing this? I think for me the biggest blocks ironically are psychological, they are mindset. Things like imposter
你知道的，它给了你一个真正开始思考自己如何蓬勃发展的机会。对我而言，被动收入让我能够做更多的事情，比如媒体工作、品牌合作、运营这个绝对需要花费大量时间的播客、发展我的会员社区，以及花更多高质量的时间陪伴家人和朋友。那么，是什么阻碍了我们所有人立刻冲出去做这件事呢？我认为对我来说，最大的障碍具有讽刺意味的是心理层面的，是思维模式。比如冒名顶替综合征，
syndrome, you know, who am I to create a course or write a book or start a membership? I think the guilt about earning more is a big one too because in my experience many mental health professionals can feel uncomfortable about making money beyond their client work. Feeling like you have a lack of time is another big one too. I'm already busy, I'm already at capacity, I don't have the time to build passive income streams or to figure out how to do it. And of course having a fear of technology. How would I begin to fathom how to make all of this happen? You might think I've got a great idea for a book or a course but I don't know how to get that out of here
你知道的，“我是谁，怎么配去创建一个课程、写一本书或创办一个会员社区？”我认为，对于赚得更多而产生内疚感也是一个巨大的障碍，因为以我的经验来看，许多心理健康专业人士会对通过客户工作之外的途径赚钱感到不自在。觉得自己没有时间是另一个巨大的障碍。我已经很忙了，工作已经饱和了，我没有时间建立被动收入流，也没有时间去琢磨怎么做。当然，还有对技术的恐惧。我怎么能弄懂这一切是怎么运作的呢？你可能会想：“我有一个关于书或课程的好点子，但我不知道怎么把它从脑子里拿出来，
and into some form where someone can pay me money for it. The good news is that you do not need to be able to reinvent the wheel. If you have knowledge and expertise, which you do, there's definitely a way to package it all up, to help others whilst also benefiting yourself. So what are our first steps for beginning to build passive income? Where on earth do you actually start? So I think it's important to think about leveraging our time for our money, but also leveraging what you already know. What options are there? Well, it's likely that you've read a few books in your time. Have you considered writing one? It might be a book, it might be an e-book. If you've ever considered it, just do it. My books, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, The
变成某种别人愿意付钱购买的形态。”好消息是，你不需要重新发明轮子。如果你拥有知识和专业技能（而你确实拥有），绝对有一种方法可以将它们打包，在帮助别人的同时让自己受益。那么，开始构建被动收入的第一步是什么？你到底该从哪里开始呢？所以，我认为思考如何用时间和金钱进行杠杆运作是很重要的，同时也要利用你已有的知识。有哪些选择呢？好吧，你可能读过不少书。你考虑过写一本吗？可能是一本书，也可能是一本电子书。如果你曾考虑过，那就去做吧。我的书——《临床心理学家合集》、
Grief Collective and all of the others, have been incredible sources of impact. People really like them but they've also earned me revenue too. How about online courses, webinars, master classes? You've likely attended loads of these in the past. You may even have paid for them. What do you know that you could create and package into a course? Memberships and subscriptions. Have a think about those that you already sign up to. Perhaps it is Netflix. Perhaps it's Amazon Prime. Perhaps it's Disney. Perhaps it's Pret a Monge, perhaps it's HelloFresh, Apple Fitness, think about what you get for your money
《悲伤合集》（The Grief Collective）以及所有其他作品，都产生了不可思议的影响力。人们真的很喜欢它们，它们也为我带来了收入。在线课程、网络研讨会、大师班怎么样？你过去可能参加过很多这样的活动。你甚至可能为此付过费。你知道些什么可以将其创建并打包成一门课程呢？会员制和订阅制。想想那些你已经订阅的服务。也许是网飞。也许是亚马逊Prime。也许是迪士尼。也许是Pret A Manger（璞臻），也许是HelloFresh（好侍厨），也许是Apple Fitness，想想你花的钱得到了什么，
and actually what you need to be able to offer your clients might be less than you imagine. Perhaps you could create an online space or community, maybe even a membership too. Now, I know as a psychologist, I have a ton of self-help and mental health focused books. How about the resources that we accumulate along the way too? Workbooks, reflective journals, digital downloads can all be really simple ways of beginning to generate passive or recurring revenue.
实际上，你需要向客户提供的内容可能比你想象的要少。也许你可以创建一个在线空间或社区，甚至是一个会员社区。现在我知道，作为一名心理学家，我有一大堆自助和心理健康相关的书籍。我们在这一路上积累的各种资源又如何呢？工作手册、反思日记、数字下载物，都可以成为开始产生被动或持续收入的非常简单的方法。
Now I've got something really special for you. I recently had my first ever in-person recording of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast and it was in the home of the brilliant Lisa Johnson who is an expert in passive income. She agreed to talk with us about why passive and recurring revenue is so incredibly important for psychologists and mental health professionals and therefore why this could be a game changer for you. Let's dive in to my and Lisa's chat and I will catch you on the other side. Hi Lisa, thank you for inviting me to your beautiful home. No worries, nice to have you here. Oh thank you. So tell us a little bit about you for anyone who hasn't heard of Lisa Johnson
现在我有一个非常特别的消息要告诉你。我最近进行了我的“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）历史上的首次线下录制，地点就在杰出的丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）的家中，她是一位被动收入专家。她同意与我们探讨为什么被动收入和持续性收入对心理学家和心理健康专业人士如此极其重要，以及为什么这能为你带来颠覆性的改变。让我们切入我和丽莎的谈话，稍后节目见。嗨，丽莎，谢谢你邀请我来到你美丽的家。不用谢，很高兴你能来。哦，谢谢。那么，请给还不认识丽莎·约翰逊的人简单介绍一下你自己吧。
before. So the main thing I am is a mum of twins. I'm a travel lover. But the thing that I'm known for is I wrote a Sunday Times bestselling book called Make Money Online. And that book was just because, you know, when I started in business myself, I was 30,000 in debt. This was only eight years ago. So it feels like a long time ago, but it wasn't actually that long and in the last six years I've made 20 million just you know helping people use the knowledge that they have in whatever field they're in to make money online. I'm a psychologist and so I was really trying to go for the poker face but you just told me you made 20 million. Your poker face isn't that good. Yeah it's not that good, it's not that good but it's you know it's It's not that good. But it's admirable, really impressive stuff.
我主要的身份是一位双胞胎妈妈。我是一个旅游爱好者。但我为人所知的是，我写过一本《星期日泰晤士报》畅销书，叫做《在线赚钱》（Make Money Online）。写那本书只是因为，你知道的，当我刚开始创业时，我背负了3万英镑的债务。这只是在八年前。所以听起来好像是很久以前的事了，但其实并没有那么久。而在过去的六年里，我赚了2000万，原因很简单，就是帮助人们利用他们无论身处什么领域所拥有的知识在网上赚钱。我是一名心理学家，所以我真的很努力地保持扑克脸，但你刚才直接告诉我你赚了2000万。你的扑克脸没那么好。是的，确实没那么好，没那么好，但你知道的，
Yeah, it's been a wild few years and I didn't set out to become a multimillionaire, but I think that when you're trying to help people with something that you're really passionate about, money follows. I really believe that profit follows passion and I'm passionate about helping mainly women, but we help all sorts of people but women to have financial freedom and by doing that by helping people just use the knowledge in their head to be able to make more money that gives them that and so yeah it's been crazy. I actually love what you say there about what does someone always say oh could I just could have a word with you about this? I just wanna pick your brain.
这确实没那么好。但这是令人钦佩、非常了不起的成就。是的，这几年像坐过山车一样疯狂，我一开始并没有立志成为千万富翁，但我认为，当你试图用你真正热衷的事物去帮助别人时，金钱就会随之而来。我坚信利润追随热情，我热衷于帮助主要是女性——但我们也帮助各种各样的人——帮助女性获得财务自由。通过这种方式，通过帮助人们利用脑海中的知识赚取更多钱，从而赋予他们这种能力，所以，是的，这太疯狂了。我真的很喜欢你刚才说的那种情况，人们总是说：“哦，我能跟你聊聊这个吗？我只想借用一下你的智慧。”
And I think when psychologists are trying to think about a niche, it's probably, that's probably a really good place to start. What they'd feel comfortable having a 10 minute chat about in their passion. It doesn't have to be everything you know. It can be one thing that they think, this is the bit that I love helping people with.
我想当心理学家在考虑细分领域时，这可能是一个非常好的起点。他们愿意就自己的热情所在轻松地聊上十分钟。这不需要涵盖你所知道的一切。可以仅仅是其中的某一件事，他们会觉得：“这是我最喜欢帮助别人的部分。”
This is the bit that I always see the difference when I help people with. So let's make passive income, recurring revenue really, passive income is a bit of an outdated word these days, but recurring revenue from that. So help us understand then what might recurring revenue, passive income look like? It can look like all kinds of things, so it could be a course. So most people, they trade their time for money. So if you are in any kind of therapy, you generally give someone an hour and you get back an amount for that cost. It doesn't have to be that way. And what we found is if we take that person who knows that information, and most
这是我每次帮助别人时，总能看到带来改变的部分。所以，让我们从这上面创造被动收入，准确地说是持续性收入——现在“被动收入”这个词在当今有点过时了。那么，让我们来理解一下，持续性收入或被动收入可能是什么样的？它可以是各种各样的形式，比如一门课程。大多数人都是用时间换金钱。所以如果你从事任何形式的治疗，你通常是给别人一个小时，然后从这个成本中获得一定金额的回报。情况不一定非要如此。而我们发现，如果我们把那个掌握这些信息的人——大多数人
people are asking the same thing at some point. So you put the answer into a course, a workshop, an ebook, you know a membership even where people just want support and then you can charge you know times however many people. So instead of doing let's say a hundred pound for one hour you can still have the same hour but you could have a hundred people paying you a hundred pounds making a lot more money with that one hour. So you're leveraging your time and all passive income is really, is not trading time for money. People have kind of turned it into this unrealistic thing of money raining down on you when you sleep. That isn't really what happens. You do have a lot of work at the beginning. You
在某些时候都在问同样的问题——把答案做成一门课程、一个工作坊、一本电子书，甚至是一个人们只需要支持的会员社区，然后你就可以向——你知道的——乘以人数的收费。所以，与其说比如收一百英镑做一个小时的咨询，你仍然可以付出同样的一个小时，但你可以有一百个人每人付给你一百英镑，通过这一个小时赚到多得多的钱。所以你是在撬动你的时间。所有的被动收入，实际上就是不再用时间换金钱。人们把它变成了一种不切实际的东西，仿佛钱在你睡觉时从天上掉下来。那并不是真正发生的事。你在开始时确实有很多工作要做。你
need to set something up that you can sell over and over again. But that's when it becomes really passive. I love it when I suddenly get like £48 drop in my bank and I haven't even mentioned it that day. It's just there. And it's just there, it just appears. And if you get a message like from Katra saying success or congratulations you made a sale, you're like, thanks, that feels good. What felt really good for me was I was helping people I was helping people one to one. I couldn't go on holiday. Because if I went on holiday, I wouldn't get money and I couldn't be sick because then I wouldn't make money for that like two weeks or whatever. So it's like there
需要建立一个可以反复销售的东西。但也就是从那时起，它才真正变得被动。我最喜欢的是，当我甚至没有在那天提起它时，我的银行账户里突然多出了48英镑。它就在那里。它就在那里，它自己出现了。如果你收到一条来自Katra的消息，说“成功”或“恭喜你完成了一笔销售”，你就会想：“谢谢，感觉真好。”对我来说真正感觉好的是，我以前在帮助人，我一对一地帮助人。我不能去度假。因为如果我去度假，我就赚不到钱；我也不能生病，因为那样的话，在那两周左右的时间里我就无法赚钱。所以我想：一定有更好的办法。
has to be a better way. And so when I found passive income, what I love is we still can make a lot of money when I'm traveling. Like I don't work for the whole of July August and half of September But we make the same amount in that time as we do the rest of the year And I think that's really important because we don't know what's gonna happen to us ever and when we might be needed elsewhere Hmm, and I think for my audience of a psychologist and mental health professionals, that's really key Especially they've just got a small practice of themselves Then it's thinking, if I take two weeks off at Christmas, that's a really squeaky time in January.
因此，当我发现了被动收入时，我最喜欢的是，即使我在旅行，我们仍然可以赚很多钱。比如我在七月、八月和九月的一半时间里都不工作，但我们在那段时间赚到的钱和一年中其他时间一样多。我认为这真的很重要，因为我们永远不知道会发生什么，什么时候我们可能会被需要去别的地方。嗯，我想对于我这群由心理学家和心理健康专业人士组成的受众来说，这绝对是关键所在，尤其是当他们只开办了一个小型私人诊所时。然后就会想：“如果我在圣诞节请假两周，那在一月份就会手头非常紧。”
Yeah, and they might decide not to take two weeks off, but if they get sick for a month or three months, that's a problem. And actually, it doesn't need to be because the world has changed. We do have the internet, email lists, social media. We don't need to work in the way that we did before. People always used to say, the harder you work, the more money you make. Not that I believe that you should work hard. I think it's, you know, I have a very strong work ethic.
是的，他们可能会决定不请假两周，但如果他们生病一个月或三个月，那就是个问题了。实际上，这本不必成为问题，因为世界已经变了。我们拥有互联网、电子邮件列表、社交媒体。我们不需要像以前那样工作了。人们过去常常说：“你工作越努力，赚的钱就越多。”并不是说我认为你应该努力工作。我认为——你知道的——我有很强烈的职业道德。
I believe much more in working smarter than harder. You don't have to work quite as much to make more. It's interesting meeting you today because actually over the weekend, I was at a magic show and some there was a social media competition to kind of you know you like a bit of competition but another bit to kind of comment on this this chap's social media post of us in the audience yeah and I'd commented on it and then someone else in the audience came and found me and said oh oh you um talked to Marianne
我更坚信聪明工作胜过努力工作。你不需要工作那么多就能赚得更多。今天见到你真是有趣，实际上在周末时，我去看了魔术表演，现场有一个社交媒体比赛——你知道的，大家都喜欢一点小竞争——其中一项要求是评论这位魔术师在社交媒体上发布的关于我们观众的帖子。是的，我评论了，然后观众席里的另一个人过来找到我说：“哦，哦，你……你跟玛丽安·特伦特谈过话吗？”我就说：“是的。”她就说：“哦，好吧，你可能不认识我，但我只是想对你说声谢谢，因为实际上在几年前我妈妈去世了，有人给我买你的悲伤心理书，这本书太有用了，真的帮了我大忙。”我想这显然感觉太棒了。
Trent and I was like yes and she was like oh well you don't know me but I just wanted to say thank you because actually a couple of years ago my mum died and someone bought me your grief book and it's been so helpful it really helped me and I think that really obviously feels amazing yeah it's the impact and knowing that actually it's still okay for me to have made passive income on that, but it's still connect in a way that actually is a really valuable resource. And I think talking to this audience, it's really difficult because people think, well, maybe people will think badly of me. I get that. And actually we have that with most of the people that start something because they are helping others Because they want to make an impact in the world. They want to change the world
是的，这就是影响力，并且知道实际上我从那本书中获得被动收入仍然是件好事，但它仍然以一种真正有价值的资源的方式产生连接。我想跟这个群体谈谈真的很困难，因为人们会觉得：“嗯，也许别人会因此看不起我。”我理解这一点。实际上，我们遇到的绝大多数刚开始起步的人都有这种心态，因为他们是在帮助他人，因为他们想对世界产生影响。他们想改变世界。
Sometimes they certainly want to change how people feel I think that's the hardest thing for some reason. I think more in the uk We have been brought up to believe that we can either help people or make money And I don't know why we think it's mutually exclusive We can do both we can help loads of people and we can make a lot of money. And there are plenty of people that we see online doing that. So yeah, I think it's a mindset thing that we do have to get our head around.
有时他们确实想改变人们的感受。我认为出于某种原因，这是最难的事情。我认为尤其是在英国，我们从小受到的教育让我们相信，要么我们去帮助别人，要么我们去赚钱。我不知道为什么我们认为这两者是水火不容的。我们可以两全其美，我们可以帮助很多人，我们也可以赚很多钱。我们在网上看到很多人都在这么做。所以，是的，我认为这是一种我们必须想通的心态问题。
But, you know, people say all the time, you've changed my life to me. You've changed my life. I've made money, but I've changed their life. Why can't it be both? Such powerful food for thought. Yeah, absolutely. absolutely you know life should work on your terms and you should feel proud of what you do but also I think a word that feels really uncomfortable for lots of psychologists is the word wealthy and wealth and when
但是，你知道的，人们总是对我说：“你改变了我的生活。你改变了我的生活。”我赚了钱，但我改变了他们的生活。为什么不能两者兼得呢？真是富有启发的深刻见解。是的，绝对如此。绝对的，你知道的，生活应该按你自己的规则运转，你应该为自己所做的事感到骄傲。同时，我也认为有一个词让很多心理学家感到非常不舒服，那就是“富有”和“财富”。当我第一次拥有财务顾问，他们开始谈论这些词，甚至拥有一个财务顾问时——
I first had a financial advisor and they started talking about those words and even having a financial advisor, you know, who am I to have a financial advisor? Yeah, log into your wealth account but you have to become more comfortable with thinking about that. You deserve to be recompensed for the really hard work that you do. And when we think about people like you, it's not like you've woken up one day and know this stuff. The amount of training and education and time that you've put, you know, you've had to put in to knowing what you know and experience as well.
“我是谁，怎么配拥有一个财务顾问？”是的，登录你的财富账户，但你必须对思考这些事情感到更加习惯。你理应为你所做的非常艰辛的工作获得报酬。当我们想到像你这样的人时，你并不是某天醒来就懂这些东西的。你投入到掌握这些知识和经验中的培训、教育和时间……
Why should you be doing that for a small amount? You know, it's okay for you to earn now that you've learned all of this stuff and you're helping people. Yeah, so true. So I first started my degree in 1999. I qualified as a qualified psychologist in 2011 and I then started my private practice in 2019 and I was sobbing at my kitchen sink that morning on my first private client thinking I wasn't
凭什么你要为一点点报酬去做这件事？你知道的，既然你已经学了所有这些东西并且在帮助别人，你现在赚钱是完全可以的。是的，太对了。所以我是在1999年开始读学位的。我在2011年成为了一名合格的心理学家，然后我在2019年开办了我的私人诊所。那天早上，在我的第一个私人客户到来之前，我在厨房的水槽边泣不成声，觉得自己不够好。
enough. I didn't know enough. All that? All that. All that. And we do. You do know enough. And actually, you know, yes, you can use the psychology aspect and sell that. But what we found is we get lots of people that want to make passive income with us. We have a conversation with them. And it's not actually their profession that they end up using for their passive income, because they do know a lot, but they also have a lot of life experience. So we've had people who have been through, you know, divorces and worked out how to do it themselves, how to do all the forms themselves and save themselves money.
懂得还不够。所有这些？所有这些。所有这些。而我们确实懂。你懂的已经足够多了。实际上，你知道的，是的，你可以利用心理学方面并将其商业化。但我们发现，有很多人希望和我们一起创造被动收入。我们与他们交谈，最终他们用来创造被动收入的其实并不是他们的本职专业，因为他们虽然懂得很多，但也拥有大量的生活经验。所以我们遇到过经历过——你知道的——离婚，然后自己摸索出如何处理，如何自己搞定所有表格并省下钱的人。
They now help other people to do that and they charge for it because anyone that's just a couple of steps further along than someone else, anyone that wants to pick your brain, you can sell that information. I remember the first passive income product that I bought was how to get around Disney and we 200 twos. And I was like, like, this is interesting that she's put this together, because she's been to Disneyland a few times. And I rang her and I said, I've just bought this product from you. It was like $10. I said, do you really make money from this? And she said, I make around a hundred thousand every month from it. Because I'm in every Disney Facebook group and it's like a military operation going to Disney and all people want to know is how do I get around this easiest? And so I just wrote it and she wrote it once. She updates it every now and again.
他们现在帮助其他人做这件事并为此收费，因为任何只比别人领先几步的人，任何想向你讨教的人，你都可以把这些信息卖给他。我记得我买的第一个被动收入产品是关于如何游玩迪士尼的，花了20多美元。当时我就想：“这挺有意思的，她把这些整理出来了，因为她去过迪士尼好几次。”我打电话给她说：“我刚从你这里买了这个产品，大约10美元。我想知道你真的靠这个赚钱吗？”她说：“我每个月靠这个赚大约十万。因为我在每一个迪士尼的Facebook群组里，去迪士尼就像是一场军事行动，所有人只想知道一件事：我怎样才能最轻松地玩转这里？”于是我就写了下来，她只写了一次。她偶尔会更新一下。
And then she just keeps making money from it. But there's so much money to be made in just the knowledge you have on all sorts of life experience. Wow. And I think especially with a lot of my audience being aspiring psychologists, you know, it might not be ethical to be putting out qualified mental health advice, but there's loads of stuff, loads of stuff they know. I know one of your audience made money selling people stuff on hula hooping. Yeah, she did so well. She was making like 20, 30,000 a month teaching people how to hula hoop. But we've had all sorts, growing cut flowers, potty training, just random things, dating, using internet dating. Yeah, anything you can imagine. Somebody has written a course or a membership on it because with a membership,
然后她就源源不断地靠它赚钱。仅凭你掌握的关于各种生活经验的知识，就能赚到这么多的钱。哇。而且我认为，尤其是我的很多受众都是有志成为心理学家的人，你知道的，发布合格的心理健康建议可能不太合乎道德，但他们知道很多东西，有大量的东西。我知道你们群体里有一个人通过教别人转呼啦圈来卖货赚钱。是的，她做得太棒了。她教别人怎么转呼啦圈，每个月能赚两三万。但我们有各种各样的人，种植切花、戒除纸尿裤、各种随机的事情、约会、使用网络约会软件。是的，你能想象到的任何事情，
you don't even have to actually know your subject, you have an interest in it and you bring in other people who know the subject to teach, you are just the curator of the membership and so there is really a way to do this for everybody. Yes there is and you're running a challenge soon, very soon, Race to Recurring Revenue and you're always very upfront that you know when you've done this amazing free thing, there is an opportunity to work with you at the end if people choose, but there's no obligation to do that. And most people don't.
都有人为它写了一门课程或创建了一个会员社区。因为有了会员社区，你甚至不需要精通你的学科，你只要对它感兴趣，然后引入其他精通该学科的人来授课，你只需要成为会员社区的策展人，所以真的有一种方法可以适合每个人。是的，确实如此。你很快就要发起一个挑战了，就在非常快的时候，“冲刺持续性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue），你总是非常坦诚地表示，你知道当你做了这个精彩的免费活动后，最后会有一个与你合作的机会，如果人们选择的话，但没有任何义务。而且大多数人其实都不会选择合作。
Like, if we're honest about it, I think about a 5% of people do come in and work with me. But what I love about this challenge is that the people that do it that can't really afford, they're not ready, they're not in a position to come and work with me, they still make money from it. We have people telling us all the time, I've now on 10,000 pound months because of your challenge.
老实说，我觉得大约只有5%的人会进来和我合作。但我对这个挑战最喜爱的一点是，那些参与其中、实际上还负担不起、还没准备好、还没有处于能够来和我合作的位置的人，他们仍然能从中赚钱。我们一直听到有人告诉我们：“因为你的挑战，我现在每个月能赚一万英镑了。”
That's how I sleep at night. If we're gonna make money from things, let's give some free value as well. And sometimes those people make a lot of money and then they come in the next year anyway. So it's a win-win. Absolutely. Lisa, thank you so much for your time it's been really really
这就是我能安然入睡的原因。如果我们打算从某些事情中赚钱，那就也提供一些免费的价值。有时这些人赚了很多钱，然后第二年他们还是会加入进来。所以这是一个双赢的局面。绝对是的。丽莎，非常感谢你抽出时间，真的非常非常
lovely and I think this will be a really valuable chat for my audience. Oh no worries really nice to be here. Hope your challenge goes really well for you. Thank you. Oh how lovely was that and thank you so much to Lisa for welcoming me into her beautiful home. How inspiring it was to speak with Lisa, someone who has helped thousands of people to build sustainable income streams for themselves and their families. You can work with Lisa for free. She is running a passive income challenge which starts on Monday the 10th of February 2025. Lisa Johnson's Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge is a brilliant way to identify your best passive income idea, overcome imposter syndrome and mindset blocks,
美好，我认为这对我的受众来说会是一次非常有价值的交谈。哦，不用谢，很高兴能来到这里。希望你的挑战一切顺利。谢谢。哦，那真是太美妙了。非常感谢丽莎欢迎我来到她美丽的家。与丽莎交谈是多么令人鼓舞啊，她帮助了成千上万的人为自己和家人建立可持续的收入来源。你可以免费与丽莎合作。她正在举办一场被动收入挑战，将于2025年2月10日星期一开始。丽莎·约翰逊的“冲刺持续性收入挑战”是确定你的最佳被动收入创意、克服冒名顶替综合征和思维障碍的绝佳方法，
and to develop a strategic plan to launch your income stream. If this episode has sparked your curiosity, I'd love for you to take the next step with me. You can do that by joining Lisa Johnson's Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge, scan the QR code on screen, or check out the link in the description or the show notes. Please also check out my content on passive income on my website which is
并能制定出推出收入流的战略计划。如果这一集激发了你的好奇心，我希望你能和我一起迈出下一步。你可以通过参加丽莎·约翰逊的“冲刺持续性收入挑战”来做到这一点，扫描屏幕上的二维码，或查看简介或节目笔记中的链接。请同时查看我网站上的被动收入相关内容，网址是
www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk then go to the learn with me online learning tabs. Please let me know in the comments what passive income idea you are considering, who you are, what area you work in, please do chat with and support others in the comments too. If you resonate with what they're talking about consider subscribing and liking their channels too. If you enjoyed this episode please do like, subscribe, share, comment, do all of those good things. If you are listening on mp3 please do subscribe to the show it really is the kindest thing you can do for free for any podcaster
www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk，然后点击“与我一起学习”（learn with me）在线学习标签页。请在评论区告诉我你正在考虑什么被动收入创意、你是谁、你在什么领域工作，也请在评论区与其他人交流并互相支持。如果你对他们谈论的内容深有共鸣，也可以考虑订阅和点赞他们的频道。如果你喜欢这一集，请点赞、订阅、分享、评论，做所有这些美好的事情。如果你是通过mp3收听，请务必订阅本节目，这对于你所欣赏的任何播客创作者来说，
that you rate. Thank you so much for listening or watching to this episode I do hope you have found it helpful. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
真的是你能免费做出的最贴心的支持。非常感谢你收听或观看本集节目，我希望你觉得它对你有所帮助。我叫亚娜（Yana），是一名心理健康实习从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现书中关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。成为临床心理学家的途径竟然有这么多，而且没有一条完美的必经之路，这让我感到十分惊叹。这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，让我觉得“不，我没有做错”，从而减轻了对自己的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下来。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。